Speaker 1: Hi, I'm Ferren Cousins in for David
Pakman, and this is the The David Pakman Show
show, obviously biggest news in the world
right now.
We've got to just jump right into this and
that is the deteriorating situation in Afghanistan.
Over the weekend, the Afghani president was
forced to evacuate the country, leaving the
capital in Kabul to fall to the Taliban.
The Taliban have been encroaching throughout
the country over the last week or so in really
spectacular fashion, you know, just taking
over as much as they can.
And now it appears with them having seized
the capital, we're in for quite the situation.
Right.
And if you've been following social media
over the weekend, I'm sure you've seen plenty
of people with opinions about what should
and should not happen in the country.
Right now.
You've got the corporate controlled media
and, of course, all the Republicans out there
telling us we've got to double down Biden
himself, sending 5000 more troops over the
last week back to Afghanistan when we're supposed
to be getting all of our people out of Afghanistan.
U.S. embassy has had to be evacuated as well.
And then, of course, you have the other side.
You have the people who say, listen, you can't
send anybody over there.
This is a 20 year, trillion dollar endless
war.
Get the hell out and stay out.
Unfortunately, it's not as easy as all of
these armchair military strategists would
have you believe.
It's not as simple as the United States.
Sending thousands of troops over there will
get the Taliban out of the country again and
everything will be great.
Not that simple.
It's not as simple as walking away saying,
oh, well, we created this mess.
Good luck dealing with it.
That destabilizes, you know, the region.
So what is the answer?
I don't know.
I don't know, and I'm firmly willing to admit
that I don't know, and I think that's a problem
that a lot of folks have in this business,
whether it's right or left, always desperate
to have a definitive answer as to what we
need to do.
And they're always so sure of that answer.
But folks, like I said, I think this is a
situation that's not as black and white as
a lot of people want to make it seem.
I personally do not want any U.S. troops going
back to Afghanistan.
But at the same time, we have to also look
at what we did to that country, we did this.
Over 20 years.
We helped to destabilize not just Afghanistan,
but the entire region.
With our ridiculous and false foreign policy
based on lies.
And Obama kept us there.
Trump acted like he was going to get us out,
you know, tried to negotiate with the Taliban,
but that didn't do much good.
And so Biden comes along and says, well, we're
going to finish getting out of there.
We didn't.
Now we're going back.
So what is the solution you?
Can we just sit here and say, OK, Taliban,
Afghanistan is yours, we screwed it up, maybe
you can do better?
I obviously don't think we can do that.
Is the answer sending thousands more troops
back to the country to just put it back in
the situation it was in before we even left?
That's also a terrible idea.
Unfortunately.
There's no easy answers.
And any answer we have has to address the
fact that the United States has made this
situation so much worse.
The Taliban now has their hands on all these
U.S. weapons that we've been sending over
there for decades now.
They've got the strongholds, they have forced
us out, they have forced the Afghan government
out.
And they say they're now waiting for a peaceful
transfer of power.
So, again, I don't have a definitive answer,
one suggestion I have at this point.
Is we need to do what George W. Bush originally
talked about doing until he pissed off all
our allies is we need a coalition.
The United States has proven that we can't
handle the situation there, we never went
in with an actual strategy.
So it's kind of hard 20 years after the fact,
to really be able to get a good, solid strategy,
a really good ground game going because we
never had one to begin with.
So everybody else that comes along, all the
other leaders, Obama, Trump and Biden, they're
having to piece it together as they go.
And nobody got it right.
I mean, what's happening right now in Afghanistan
is proof that nobody got it right.
The only difference is that for all of those
years, the Taliban really only had control
on the outskirts.
You know, the really rural areas of Afghanistan.
That's that's where they were able to, you
know, see progress.
That's where we were able to fight them back.
And as soon as we leave, they come back.
So the answer is not obviously sending more
troops over there for another 20 years, so
we have another generation of American soldiers
growing up as part of this war machine, that
that's not that's not tenable.
That's not something we can do.
I do think the the best path forward at this
point, and again, I'm not a military strategist,
don't claim to be, but if we do not have a
solid coalition of allies, if we cannot get
other countries involved.
To pledge.
To protect this area, you know, if we have
to negotiate with the Taliban, then we have
to negotiate at this point.
But honestly, I don't know what else.
And it all stems from those failures of the
war on terror.
We have had Republicans try this, we have
had Democrats try this, this is now bipartisan
failure with regards to our Afghanistan foreign
policy.
So the solution is not going to come from
the United States.
We need people that are better at this, we
need people who can look at it a little more
objectively than the United States can, because
we're still stuck in that war on terror mentality
that followed the attacks of 9/11.
We're still not thinking clearly at this point,
and again, what's happening right now is further
proof of that.
So if we can't get some cooler heads in there,
if we can't get some real, true allies, you
know, maybe other nations in the region, that
can help us out.
Then this is what it is and we're stuck with
this mess that we created.
And in the meantime, until we figure this
out, the United States need to say, listen,
we're going to take Afghan refugees.
Over the weekend, tens of thousands of people
daily trying to get out of the country because
they see what's happening, they understand
this is for real.
OK, this isn't a temporary insurgency here
that we're seeing, this is what their life
may become now.
And I would say after 20 years of occupying
their country, after helping to destabilize
it, I'd say that's the least we could do,
is take these people into our country.
And that is the next step that I want to see
this Biden administration take.
Acknowledge the failures of the United States,
acknowledge that we don't have the answers
yet, and that is a terrifying thing for a
country to admit.
And I guarantee you you'll never hear them
say that.
But at least we can do that.
Me, everybody watching this, all of the other
people left and right out there with the armchair
punditry admit that we don't know how to correctly
handle this situation.
Because it sucks to have to admit that you
don't know it, but I think at this point that's
where we're at and I don't think anybody can
definitively say that.
Yes, we I know for certain we have to do this
or we can't do that.
It's not that simple, but we're going to continue
to watch as the corporate media.
CNN is already out there.
The major newspapers are already out there.
Oh, my God, this is horrible.
We got to get troops back there.
They're going to push for war because war
means ratings, war means advertisements, and
that's what makes them money.
On the other side of all of this, you have
the Republicans out there nonstop over the
weekend telling us that this is a failure
of the Biden administration.
This failure rests solely on his shoulders.
And whether it's fair or not, it does.
He is the leader of the country right now.
This was a decision that was made.
And so if it succeeds or fails, that is on
him.
And you may think it's fair, you may think
it's not fair, but it doesn't matter, politically
speaking, yes, it is on him and Republicans
are going to do everything they can to use
that to their advantage, especially heading
into the midterms.
As we all know, Republicans have struggled
terrifically, trying to come up with any kind
of talking point to take down Joe Biden.
You know, going as far a couple of months
ago to blame him for the Chick fil A sauce
shortage.
This is one that might stick and that's even
more terrifying, folks.
Because of the midterm elections, and especially
if the twenty twenty four presidential elections
become about failed foreign policy and people
get mad at the Democrat who inherited all
of it.
And again, I think it's rather unfair for
that to happen.
But I understand that that is what is going
to happen.
Then we're going to end up with something
terrible.
That's a situation where you end up with somebody
like Tom Cotton coming out and saying, oh,
my God, we've got to get back over there.
Look at all this instability the Democrats
created.
The terrorists have taken over.
I've been there.
I know what it's like over there and I know
what we can do.
And people will flock to that, I promise you.
I can promise you that because we've seen
it happen, we saw it happen in the 2004 election.
Turmoil in the Middle East.
And the Republicans, unfortunately, did a
much better job of messaging, saying we're
the only ones that can keep you safe.
They did it through misinformation, they did
it through lies, they did it through fake
news and all of that.
Yes, but it worked on the American public.
So twenty, twenty four could end up being
a repeat of the 2004 election based on that
simple fact.
And again, that's the situation where you
end up with somebody worse, you end up with
the worst kind of warhawk at the top of that
Republican ticket, who is going to do unimaginable
things over there in the Middle East where
all of this is taking place, because it's
not just going to be about Afghanistan, either.
They're going to throw in Iran.
They're going to throw in Syria, they're going
to say, look at all these Democratic failures
abroad.
That's bad news.
That is bad news for the Democratic Party.
And it's bad news for the United States as
well, and it's bad news for everybody over
there in the Middle East because, again, we
end up with somebody worse and I pick Tom
Cotton because he is somebody that served.
This could be the kind of event that a guy
like him needs to really bolster up his poll
numbers, because trust me, he's not doing
well so far.
And all the little straw polls for twenty,
twenty four.
So this could be the moment that Tom Cotton
emerges as their guy, as the Republican's
guy.
You know, Rhonda Santos doesn't have that,
Ted Cruz certainly doesn't have that, Donald
Trump obviously doesn't have that, although
he is going to try to use this to his advantage
as well.
But the point is, we can't go back to a situation,
whether it is with a Democrat or a Republican,
where we think that we can bomb our way out
of the problem, that's never going to work.
We tried it for 20 years.
And an abrupt pull out here saying, well,
best of luck to you all, while it's best for
U.S. troops, sure, we've destabilize the region,
created hundreds of thousands of, you know,
evacuate refugees at this point, not just
evacuees, but refugees with nowhere to go.
And we have to own that as a country, as an
administration, they have to own that.
They may not have started this mess.
But they've been with it every step of the
way, unfortunately.
So we have to do better, we have to do better
for these people, we have to do better for
the world, and we have to get more people
on our side willing to take a leadership role,
take it away from us.
I feel.
And we can offer the support that they need.
I do not want another conflict in the Middle
East, I do not want more war, I do not want
more dead soldiers, whether it's U.S. soldiers
or whether it's a foreign country soldiers,
we don't need that at all.
So we have to put our best and brightest together,
we got to get the intelligence and I don't
mean like covert and I mean like literal intelligence,
the smart people in the room need to take
things over and they need to get with the
other smartest people around the country and
try to figure out a way that this doesn't
end with more bombs and more bloodshed.
But unfortunately, I do not think that the
cooler heads are going to prevail in this
situation, and that is not going to end well
for anybody.
I'm Ferrin Cousins in for David Pakman, we'll
be right back.